a brigar por anos terei convidado para
estar aqui é proprietário
enquanto isso o governo avalia que o
grupo do shopping com isso tão
sintonizado em tauá finados
estava a pensar quanto é difícil de ver
de hoje em que muito se preocupam com
lata oval agecom elsen afinal em
conjunto é verdade é que nós pudéssemos
usuários nesta afirmação neste com o
site todos os cargos
educar para o mesmo lado teríamos
seguramente muito melhor e teve que
trabalhar um pouco isto é uma forma de
partilharmos saber pra temos
experiências motivar-nos alguém e é
verdade também é que efetivamente sem
essa motivação nós somos cada vez mais
isolado fica cada vez mais egoístas
imagens preocupamos cruel - nos
preocupamos com um eu não sei se seria
uma pessoa em frente eu minha mulher e
meus outros dois filhos
esta família e os amigos não sei se
seria uma pessoa em frente sem a rita
seria seguramente menos menos atento
aquilo que se passa à nossa volta é e e
essa falta de atenção fez com que com
que eu na minha vida profissional que
felizmente não havia sinal de algum
sucesso de algum êxito é não brigasse
por vezes a pensar refletir que há
outras coisas pra lá em greve pra lá em
um projetor para além da encenação uma
coisa que eu tanto gosta que é o cinema
mas é também aprendi que é no cinema é o
cinema não é mais do que um espelho da
realidade de todos nós
às vezes com mais açúcar com menos
açúcar com mais comércio e menos comédia
base na fundado e inspira se na vida
real é e também haver dado que eu
poderia ser uma opção de frente da
bateria seria mais ou menos a mesma que
tem a ver connosco teve como eu cada um
de nós tem a ver com educação que
recebemos mas é é a rita fez de nós
pessoas diferentes e curiosamente não
foi fácil
recebemos é quando em frente nós
poderíamos ser
é a partir do momento em que rita brasil
nossas vidas
é como comer guarda desapareceu dois
meses antes ela não agüentava não vai
passar agora podem ser consultados mas
durante muito tempo nos traídos
preocupados com o problema dela
preocupados com a falta de apoio como
falta de soluções e andávamos à procura
do milagre que era por retardar por rita
caminhar como fazer fazer do evento um
atleta mas não podemos ser todos atletas
não podemos ser todos gostaram da mesma
cor
não podemos ser todos os mesmos cidadãos
devemos ser todos e sim preocupados com
o vizinho do lado
e foi um colega é um grande amigo e
colega também de profissão que uma vez
escreveu um texto há uns anos largos
atrás pela primeira vez em carreta
começou a andar com dani escreveu o
sorriso do rio
e nós percebemos já tinha sentido
claramente exposta animada vende muito
interativa com as pessoas mas nunca
tinha me preparado muito para pensar nos
sorriso dela ou seja estava demasiado
preocupado eu nem o resto da família é
boa a ser igual a padronizar a renta
pouco racional ea qantas torres da rita
fez nos cliques que nós precisamos na
altura para mudar alguma coisa das
nossas de vida dos outros é a rita foi
crescendo nós fomos perseguindo tal o
tal milagre da da resolução de um
problema e que ao fim de alguns anos que
estivemos também que efetivamente um
milagre ela própria era a forma dela
estar na vida ea forma dela sorrir para
os problemas que a fariam de frango ao
longo dos anos também é amiga que ela
foi puxando é ela aprendeu uma palavra
mágica que eu sempre dizia que era a
palavra mágica para o resto da vida é
aquela terminação e dela não sabe o que
é a crise a disseminação já tinha letra
a letra
sempre que você quer acrescentar então
qual é a palavra ela havia determinação
há cerca de ano e meio de anos atrás
criamos uma instituição que chama os
risos de rita e dar mais alegria de
viver
as crianças que não tiveram a sorte à
rita tempo em que cheiro e viver numa
família é equilibrada e com com
possibilidades para ajudar muito mais do
que essas outras crianças ganharam é não
tem essa visão teve uma regra inicial é
que aliás confesso que não foi o
dinamizador da extinção foram as mães
foi mulher foi mais de outras crianças
com paralisia cerebral
nós temos fazer alguma coisa e só e só
fizemos alguma coisa por uma razão muito
simples eu tinha os estatutos da figura
da provisão era o senhor cinema ou seja
emprestado estrelas a partida quando
aparecemos na televisão toda a gente
acha pato que fez 17 normal é o mundo
fantástico e houve um dia que eu por
causa de um livro escrever assumir que
tinha uma renda em casa com paralisia
cerebral é curiosamente ao explorar rita
e foi uma situação que foi discutido por
nós todos lá em casa é aos poucos a rita
acabado de fazer sair o país precisa não
é adequada para isto nós fizemos em
formarem uns quantos casos de paralisia
cerebral
trouxemos para discussão pública a
presença de brown e nessa altura as mães
causa paula mulher mãe de rita é e
outras mães com crianças com presença
igual só que vamos fazer uma distinção
que se chama os rios rita sobre talita
tinha sido precisamente o título da peça
que é um trecho de uma crônica da
opinião do colega meu que olhou
nós tínhamos vista nós vimos na
fotografia a rita querer caminhar
eu não não se preocupou com o promotor
da rita caminhar pra vocês sim eu estou
em texto o sorriso da reta e foi por
isso que saiu é surgiu essa cisão com o
nome do sorriso ainda que já falou
esta é a história de um sorriso que se
pretende é grande muito grande enquanto
as dietas e começou-se a laep ser lenta
lá eu excel então
cresceu assim numa ajuda cintos é mais
uns quantos sorriso
começou num texto singelo e sentido que
o seu ex votos e traz respiradas de
amizade como os membros florescem foram
provocando contagiando outros surpresa
hoje quando por vezes falta é vontade
para sorrir
outros vão aparecendo e entram nesta
onda de estar a olhar de frente um
problema que no momento qualquer mac os
meus 30 x machida uma bebida redonda
refinada o mil planos
tudo parece arrasada sem escolher sumiu
esses estratos sociais pais ou raças
traindo expectativas certo
e sim o juízo que se pode combater de
frança despertar consciências chegar
onde hipocrisia costuma reinar em média
diz que todos os anos no nosso país 250
bebés nascem com uma marca
deixem que chame o estigma de brasília
a cisão sorriso rita será o organismo
tende às vezes não é o contributo
voluntário que faz a diferença é a
atitude ajuda a sensibilização ea leva
aos subordinados por sorrir é bom
uma carga
eu estou agüentando subida
eu e confesso que eu nunca me
perguntaram e eu gosto muito de falar
com roger que eu ia ficar linha que é
nós tínhamos aqui não não é e arranjar a
função com alan pai ao casal a viver
mexe olhar para o problema com uma
vontade de superar ou seja não podemos
achar a solução é melhorar sim um
problema como se não fosse o problema é
e eu gosto muito de comunicar e então
quando você ficar mais uma dura é tem
agora 15 anos é eu tinha que encontrar
uma maneira de trabalhar que terminar
comigo e também ao mesmo tempo sentia
vontade de ajudar os outros
então um dia não é bom não pensei que
meu pai surgiu na tv comecei a escrever
mesmo em áreas que não pode dizer agora
vamos criar uma página
confesso que no início do mês que vem a
gente vai ser só mais um passo dentro e
altura mas foi muito tempo
a opinião das pessoas a viver ajuda por
sua vez continuar ea partir daí nunca
mais ver aí que se é que o agora eu fico
mais na minha bagagem
tanto assim é que não quero que olhem
para a defensa com com uma coisa que é
vizinho ao ataque eu não consegui fazer
muitas coisas
é eu acho que a imprensa não se a
criança fosse uma coisa nova porque só
se esperar em ben johnson alviverde
eles querem dizer que é no meu caso
claro que a eu acho trazia mais raro
no meu caso a diferença produzir só
nunca me tinha meus anéis o assunto como
os 20 normais e sim em jati é agora já
chega a uma fase que já new york 2010
confesso que não não é assim pra mim
aqui sozinha e eu fiquei assim ó eu já
tenho um rio que não a merece e minha
página
trouxe muita coisa boa porque através da
escrita e acho que não há nada como nós
nem os próprios para depois também
poderão ser ao mesmo tempo a minha
página com um sentimento que me está a
dizer eis que ele consegue sair daqui eu
nunca mais por aí
é mas as pessoas também não viajam para
agora está mesmo assim o que eu não
tenho esta é assim que nós vai mesmo
ficar forçando nós sabemos que é assim
é eu acho que é assim é nós não vemos
existir ou seja não é somente um
problema e pronto agora ficamos por aqui
que já não não é continuar sempre eo
agora com a escrita é agir da mesma
maneira não limitar nem o avião nem que
a gente pensa mesmo é o que eu quero é a
mensagem que quero aqui deixar aqui um
sorriso é fácil de me ver muita coisa e
pensamos que a passagem da prova
como como como eu vou ficar uma coisa
tenho a semana toda fora chegada é e não
tivemos tempo para nos organizarmos a
forma como vamos fazer aqui a palestra
de apresentação é e temos tido alguma
experiência em escolas elas enquanto vai
falar à escola portanto é ela foi ao rio
nista total e plena daquilo que acredito
que a equipe não teve interferência nem
dos pais nem os irmãos porque além da
chuva porque já perceberam também tem o
seu feito sozinho e que tantas vezes
às vezes não é fácil fazer uma convenção
das coisas mas eu acho que é importante
nós temos aqui é algumas notas jogando
aquilo que eu disse no início é ter uma
empresa muito caro
nós achamos que só acontece aos outros
mas quando alguma coisa de diferente nos
toca é não temos mais o que fazer disse
não transformar essa coisa algo
milharado para o mundo a cidade em que
vivemos para a nossa casa para trabalhar
com zahia é muito embora tenhamos uma
das coisas que mais gosto trabalhar na
reta
ainda temos muito a fazer e ela tem
muito a fazer pela vida é que às vezes é
mesmo é onde menos se espera em que se
encontra é a cabeça quadrada das pessoas
a lidar com a imprensa gaulesa não sei
se você quer contar agora eu já estava
ultrapassado o tempo não podemos deixar
mais um carioca os dois na parceiro pode
contar a história era então uma vez foi
fazer uma injeção uma vacina
ganha a bola mas não é essa a minha mãe
sempre montou aqui com a minha que ela
tenha início assim é profissional e ao
ai quando assim é uma fininha e eu já
estou fêmeas eu tenho que me sentei com
a forma que nós tivemos de dar a volta a
esta expressão infeliz de alguém que
deveria ter algum cuidado até porque era
um técnico segundo e só prova que havia
algum trabalho feito com rita na
socialização da tabela é nós hoje temos
essa expressão quando acontece alguma
coisa que nós não estamos em casa ou
entre amigos e para a 11ª
só uma 1 como nota final casa precisa
mais alguma coisa
espero continuar assim primeiro porém a
opinião
nada mais chato ver os casos é
essencialmente é eu acho que a rita não
é mais nem menos do que qualquer um de
vós
apesar de ficar mais cara por quem
comprar veículos
o veículo de quatro rodas é não pagar
celta é normal e não há problema mas eu
acho que se nós lutarmos contra a
indiferença do dos ditos normais e nos
preocuparmos em olhar para os outros com
olhos verdes e de sensibilização para
viver em sociedade com equilíbrio e
respeitando as diferenças e as
diferenças podem não ser só uma
deficiência motora podem ser múltiplas
podem ser até a diferença de cor podem
ser as diferenças de religião ou seja
nós temos todos viver em equilíbrio
neste mundo onde vivemos e tivermos esse
respeito só à salvador mas fazer com que
estejamos todos muito mais equilibrados
em sociedade e possamos viver e possamos
fazer aqui o que os jovens daqui a pouco
fizemos com as batas e os baldes
quero estar toda equilibrado que
exatamente foi um prazer estar aqui
partilhar estas histórias só uma nota
final se quiserem procurar a página da
rede testou no não custa nada chamas aos
olhos do rita
neste momento quando são quase 15 mil
seguidores
elas melhor pois não posso dizer que
minha pac tem 1 70 ou 80 comentários
todos dizer como é que poderiam ir à
procura é o que o que só prova que
efetivamente quando nós fazemos alguma
coisa por alguma coisa com os outros
sobre também é
olha crianças pobres do bairro
eu só rolar puderem fazer um link na
página da rede vão partilhar as
histórias que ela conta e estas festas
do s
estas peripécias e esta determinação é e
só para a nota final da roda peão
diversas crônicas
tudo leva a crer que seja um livro
porque são tantos que as pessoas que vão
subindo e já apareceram 1 mas ela ainda
diz que não é altura tem que escrever
mais tem que aprender a escrever mais
esquece as noites quebra coisa que eu
não vou deixar
obrigado caro